we've got some stunning news happening
over at the Walt Disney Company Bob Iger
the legendary Bob idea has been
reinstated as CEO the board announced
this last night that he agreed to a
two-year contract to lead the company
through what it calls a quote pivotal
period Iger ran Disney for more than 15
years before Bob chapic took over in
2020. Disney posted lower than expected
earnings in the last quarter and missed
Wall Street expectations the company
also reported losses at its streaming
division shares of Disney have fallen
about 41 so far this year Iger who is 71
said he was thrilled to return an
extremely optimistic about Disney's
future what's going on but he also said
that you know this is an unexpected turn
of events right even for him I know
people that talked to him over the
weekend and last week yeah we're close
to him and had no idea that no idea this
was going on back in 2020 he was asked
several times he was here on the show
yeah and and asked in multiple
interviews would you ever go back to
Disney I think in an interview he did
with Cara Swisher he said absolutely not
you can never go home or go home you
know you can never go home again right
and he was very happy with his life
after Disney too well there's that but
also that he was first of all remember
that Bob chapek was somebody that he had
a hand in shooting yeah he did have a
hand in choosing that and I want to
quote from Matt Bellamy at Puck who
wrote this it's not one specific thing
from the early political misjudgments in
Florida it's an unpopular and arguably
destructive reorganization from the lack
of Engagement with the creative
Community to last week's earning debacle
these are some of the things that the
board was thinking about uh and it's
sort of like remember in Dallas when
they bought back Bobby Ewing yeah woke
up from a shower because the ratings
weren't doing so well in Dallas they
bring back the star I feel it's a little
bit like that well I wonder how much all
of that weight on Bob iger's mind too
because we know he cares about the
company for sure so you'll get a kick
out of this Vlad I reached out to team
Iger last night yeah he sent a note to
his staff at 9 45 on a Sunday night
let's think about that for a second so I
sent a thing to team Iger his people
would he like to come on and explain to
us yes we would love to have it crickets
I mean of course I knew that wasn't
Jiminy Cricket yeah Jiminy Cricket Steve
Gail well and I can't wait to hear the
Back store a lot of the actors um on
Twitter are sort of like clapping and
applauding this move so it'll be very
interesting a lot of people say he's not
going to put his legacy at risk unless
there's something really big that he's
cooking up so stay tuned for that we
don't know but it could be yeah